قدره البشر على رؤيه الكون في السماء
الليل قد تختفي في غضون 20 عاما بسبب
التلوث الضوئي تحذير اطلقه علماء فلك
مقترحين تغيير الوان الاضاءه حول العالم
مشرين الى ان غياب بعض الالوان من الاضاءه
قد يكون سببا لمشاكل صحيه وقال موقع
علمي بان السنوات القليله الماضيه تفاقمت
فيها قضيه التلوث الضوئي بسرعه وذكر
العلماء بان التلوث الضوئي يضيء السماء في
الليل بمعدل يتزايد بحوالي 10% سنويا
ويقول الموقع بان الطفل الذي يولد في مكان
يمكن فيه رؤيه 250 نجما حاليا سيكون قادرا
على رؤيه 100 نجم فقط بحلول الوقت الذي
يبلغ فيه سن 18 عاما
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات